[Music]
that's a rarity to go to a roller
skating rink and find live music there
most other roller rinks have gone
digital but head to Southern California
and you'll find one of the last
remaining rinks to employ a live organ
player
[Music]
my name is Dominic Angelo si and I own
the moonlight Roller way I've been
playing rollerskating music for 70 years
there are only about 10 or 15 roller
rink Organists left in the country in
the 40s and 50s most of the rinks around
the country used live organ music and
then when Elvis Presley and the Beatles
all came into the picture in the 50s and
60s most of the rinks around the country
faced out the live organ to play
recorded music but not the moonlight
roller way Wednesday through Monday the
moonlight roller Way plays recorded
music just like most roller rinks but
one day a week Dominick gets to dust off
his Hammond organ and throwback to a
different time a Tuesday's I play from 8
o'clock till 10:30 the people that come
on Tuesday nights our mixed crowd a
number of the skaters are old-time
skaters in their 70s and 80s who like to
skate to the organ music this place is
special because it's been here for so
long it's a historical landmark people
have skated here through the years met
their boyfriends girlfriends here raised
a family bring their grandchildren and
it's something from the past and I just
want to hold on to at least one night a
week I love coming here I come every day
and I enjoyed my customers they
appreciate it and they like the music I
have no plans to stop playing the organ
I'll play it as long as I'm here
[Music]
every radio definitely has its own
personality this is the boombox your
grandmother or maybe a great-grandmother
would have carried around this reminds
me all football actually if you live in
a split-level house this is the radio
for you this radio has never been opened
before this one's a breeze there's not a
whole lot of documentation that's still
around on how to do this you're going to
read from I like it you get them in
wrong the radio blows up sometimes I
work on these radios for hours and hours
and hours and just when I think I'm
about to give up something clicks in my
mind and it works to me this radio looks
very science-fiction like and this would
be like the the console of a spaceship
that start off as a hobby and now it's
become a little bit more than that I
have several hundred at any given point
these radios are found in dumps and
garages and old closets there were
families that probably sat around these
radios and listened to the first man
land on moon FDR's fireside chats were
probably playing through these radios
digital technology sterilizes music old
radio sound a lot more organic a lot
warmer when I repair these radios I feel
like I'm giving them back their old
voice the Mortal Kombat games are some
of the most iconic of all time and when
you're winning
nothing my name is Steve Ritchie and I'm
a pinball and video game designer in the
early 90s Steve was making pinball
machines in the very same building a
couple of guys were developing the
second Mortal Kombat game upstairs was
pinball downstairs video development
Steve did the voices for a bunch of
pinball machines he designed most of the
time I do I do bad guys and this is the
voice that I have and it can be I am the
Black Knight did for ac/dc a devil I'm
on the highway so when the Mortal Kombat
creator needed a new voice for the
announcer he knew what right where to go
and pulled Steve into the recording
booth and he started telling me say it
like this
fatality he would say no more breathy
lower fatality all this beeping that
little R had to be wrong lately okay
round 1 fight oh that was it oh yeah
after you add the effects you know it's
a lower pitch
leadership well cool okay Johnny Cage
wins
Mortal Kombat has spawned a dozen video
games comic books TV shows and a film
franchise featuring this awesome techno
song but these contribution to Mortal
Kombat isn't what he's known for its
pinball because Steve he's made a lot of
pinball machines I've created more
pinball machines than anyone else in the
pinball history but whether he's a voice
in a video game or designing a pinball
machine the thing Steve loves most well
we'll let him tell you I like to put the
player in a spot of an adversarial
relationship a battle you're beating
your balls snatching and ends of things
to experience normal combat you know
it's a video game but when he says
something it's like round one fight it's
just like he's scary and you are
battling this guy hey Steve Jim just
kidding you should do it Steve
[Music]
imagine two acres of land that are
covered with Las Vegas history dating
from the 1930s up to present day and
when you walk in they tell a story the
Neon Museum was founded in 1996 and we
rescue signs there are over 200 signs in
the neon boneyard Las Vegas is a town
that is known for imploding all of its
hotels and not preserving its history
because we're always wanting to move on
to the bigger better brighter thing
there's beauty in the warned signs
they're a glimpse into the past you see
that rusted paint you see the broken
neon and it's kind of bittersweet
the folks who designed these are really
master craftsmen they can to blow the
neon that's in them the yucca motel
the intricate artwork the glassblowing
that had to go into the design of the
actual yucca the start a spire reaching
up into the sky it's becoming an art
form that's going away we preserve a lot
of those memories so people who didn't
see the signs actually on the strip are
able to come here and get a real sense
for what they were like in person
[Music]
in the 1920s and up through the 1950s
Hollywood had a particular way of
talking come around about No what are
you doing up there to person anyhow book
club really really it was called the Mid
Atlantic or transatlantic accent but we
don't speak like that anymore so what
happened to know why it disappeared we
need a little history the accent is sort
of a British American hybrid
linguistically speaking it has three
main tenants one drop the are like
mother and father to emphasize the tea
like raita and winter and three soften
her vowels like dongs and call and this
accent was acquired so there's no line
tracing it back through history some
believe it came out of early radio when
bass tones were difficult to hear but
many attribute its popularity to write
or eat it's Skinner she actually wrote a
book called speak with distinction which
was the book to help you learn the
accent either way it was a language for
the American upper class people like FDR
Katharine Hepburn Cary Grant they all
used it but after World War two the
accent dwindled in popularity with a
growing middle class and aristocratic
accent was no longer fashionable as for
Hollywood acting methods changed and the
accent was just too fake so it
disappeared mostly if you've ever seen
the show Frasier Niles and Frasier spoke
with an updated mid-atlantic accent I
love lovely
[Music]
bimbeau always an arcade favorite but if
you grew up in New York City between
1940 and 1976 playing pinball meant
breaking the law in 1933 congressman
Fiorello LaGuardia was elected mayor of
New York City one of the first items on
his agenda was to crack down on the
Mafia he honed in on mobile and slot
machines and surprisingly pinball
machines he's exceeded in getting
pinball declared in the legal game of
chance and in 1940 the city banned the
game this of course drove pinball
machines underground to seedy parlors
and even seedy air strip clubs the
public disdain for pinball wasn't as
high as it was for slot machines which
made it hard for the mayor to gain
public support for his raids on these
newly illegal pinball establishments
that was until 1941 after Pearl Harbor
the government established the salvage
for victory campaign which called on
Americans to turn in scrap metal to be
used for the war effort
enter mayor LaGuardia who took this
opportunity to seize and destroy more
than three thousand pinball machines all
in the name of helping the military of
course 30 years would pass before New
York City declared pinball game of skill
not chance and legalized it
[Music]